the two masks of tragedy and comedy the
reason they always show together that
there's a there's a thin line very and
we've talked about that in the past and
on other things where you have to laugh
at the [ __ ] that would make you cry and
people don't know we talked about this
before
well on here it wasn't on here it was
your other incarnation of the
documentary thing yeah it was for uh
jeff l uh but you know the more loss
i've had the more i've seen family
members suffer people that i love so
much if i'm on stage that night
god help people because i'm going to say
some things i probably shouldn't say
right i'm going to do a show because i
am hurting because i've got somebody
that's on life support and it's not an
excuse it's just how i'm processing it
right i'll to go to a therapist or if i
don't have time and i'm working i'll get
some venom out in a way and i'll go off
on a subject i mean you know they don't
mean to
you know the movie life is beautiful of
course you know so that's how do you not
right right so that's the the epitome of
kind of what we're talking about you
know he was making the holocaust and a
uh
the the camps seemed like a fun place
for this child which really helped the
kid i mean it right and probably helped
him too to that that's where his focus
was instead of just his survival how can
i make this a a better place in a goofy
place and there are people in today's
society that would say well how can you
clown around and how can you go people
are dying and people are suffering and i
would say to those people that's why i
need to clown around that's why i need
to joke around yeah that's why i'm
trillion where i'm where i live
[Music]
bye